Wolfram language is my Swiss Army knife
and because you can have all the things
packaging those two one thing I have the
visualization I can go into database in
making data data analysis on just one
two and this is one the most value of
Wolfram language I'm manager of
intelligence retail in summer shape
that's a supermarket brand group in
Brazil in Mathematica used for since 10
years and now I'm trying to make a team
that really understand the difference
between a traditional way of program and
how bullying can make the difference in
business and I think that today you
having some a shame more than 40
algorithms completely different in a lot
of sense price porches a planogram
design and web scrapers and the
distraction price extraction Mathematica
is a swiss knife yes so you can really
we have a lot of application that you
can do and the interesting in samar she
eats you can do simple stuffs like
things that you can do in Excel but in a
much more broader danger and very
advanced and steps for example in summer
shape we we did a lot of geographic
analysis to talk to investors I feel
that companies in a whole number of
global vision has a lack of the use of
intelligent too smart algorithms to
automate process and make better
forecasts bear algorithms to control the
flow of information inside the company
perhaps all about geographic data
analysis that we have a relationship
program Amish it and with this
relationship program we have a lot of
data about our customers so where they
live they are far from our stars they
are closer from them how can I see that
information for each one of
stores that we see some picture that are
very nice and in this world I will open
new store in displays this position how
can I know where is my customer I have
to make a market in on kilometer to
climate which we kilometers investors
come well have 17 stars now 20 left next
year and help me much more stores we can
open in San Paulo another its price
another in price for much more simple
but interesting because mathematic is
much easier to do the in other language
for example some coca coca cola as can't
be so expensive if this one liter or two
liters of coke and to control these in
10,000 items per star is a lot of fight
so we have to have the relation between
this and you can put this in your
database and you use mathematica to to
have a lot of price rules and make sure
that your price is really consistent
what's amazing that's in Wolfram
language you can solve in just on line
of code and another language have I I'm
starting Java and Python and it's not so
easy to to do some advanced math things
the advantage of both foreign language
to that is that you when you will learn
the mindset of Wolfram language you can
do it in a much more fast and much more
compact way yes and I I really feel that
business has a lot of space to use
foreign language as a powerful tool for
management Swilley management